all right we had a fight
this is a fight breaks out at the uh
woodley
uh paul fight
and it wasn't in the ring that's for
damn sure um
dude there's something i'm glad this
broke out in the stands at least these
people got to see some real action
you know jake paul is a mastermind i
will say that he has picked the perfect
people to fight
it's like the perfect amount of ability
for people to fight
the ability of fight that they have in
them tyron there's no one more
frustrating to cheer on
than tyron woodley nobody
even despail that was one of my favorite
things to watch was dave chappelle in
the distance
re i think realizing
how frustrating it is to cheer on taiwan
uh
who cares tyron woodley
it's lit it's like
and he never does you're just like
but
and he never
does
maybe he did a long time ago
you know and um and i know that he's a
nice man people love this man
but when it comes to being a fan that's
all i know he could beat my ass i'm sure
um
but
but i don't know if he would though
that's the thing about him
he did there's this
it's almost like somebody's controlling
him and they just they have
carpal tunneler he just
you're almost like how would you not
you just have every it just i don't know
there's nothing more fr it's almost like
you're stuck in traffic that's what it
feels like cheering for tyron woodley
you're like [ __ ] a punch
and they bring him out there they got
him dressed like he's being sex
trafficked honestly
they got him dressed like he's being sex
traffic dog
he's dressed like a uh like a gender
reveal party at like elon musk's trap
house i mean it's it's a unique look
and he comes i i mean i almost i don't
know if he
and i hate to say i just don't know how
mentally he there he is still
that's the part because there's always
that element of him that it's he's
missing that
that gear that everyone else seems to
want him to have
but i don't know his motivations his
motivations might have been go out there
and get paid
get that bag
don't throw any fists he may love jake
paul they may do thanksgiving together
twice a week
because i don't know if you know rich
people a new thing rich people are doing
is more thanksgivings
that's when you know
shit's getting weird
when rich people's having extra
thanksgiving
and everybody else out here
fist fighting at the papayas
everybody else out here giving birth at
arby's
and rich people out here having more
than one thanksgiving
[Music]
i refuse to cheer on tyron woodley even
though i wanted you i refuse to cheer
him i i you just it's
it's like
he just doesn't do it
he
he hates our guy he just doesn't do it
jake paul is a mastermind man and it's
also amazing you could see each fight
he's just learning to get into a
different i mean this was the first real
fight
you know nate robinson i you know that
was
i mean they were all real fights
but this was the first one where it felt
like um
i think where it really felt i don't
know
you thought nate i thought nate robinson
had a chance
ben asker and i did not think had a
chance
woodley i thought woodley i thought paul
would win
but i thought whitley had a chance man
and and i think woodley thought he had a
chance
but i think after woodley thought he had
a chance he didn't think anything else
and that's the strange thing
there's nothing worse
there's nothing i've done it for his
past five fights there's nothing worse
than cheering on tyron
woodley there really isn't
as a fighter now i'm sure as this is a
regular man
oh
he can be your hero
but damn
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one
you